welcome everyone to this uh tutorial on
the
cradle build tool here now let's talk
about the gradle installation because
this is a very important aspect to be
done because when we are doing the
installation
we have to download the cradle
executables
right so let's see that what are the
different steps is involved in the
process of the cradle installation
so when we talk about the gradle
installation so there are primary four
steps which is available the very first
one is that you have to check if the
java is installed
now if the uh java is not installed so
you can go to the open jdk
or you can go for the oracle java so you
can do the installation of the jdk on
your system
so jdk8 is something you can most
commonly use nowadays so you can install
that
once the java is downloaded and
installed then you have to do the gradle
uh
download cradle there now once the
gradle binaries are executable
or the zip file gets downloaded so you
can add the environment variables
and then you can validate if the gradle
installation is working fine as expected
not
so we will be doing the gradle
installation into our local systems and
uh into the windows platform and we'll
see that
how exactly we can go for the
installation of cradle and we'll see
that
what are the different version we are
going to install here so let's go back
to the system and see that how we can go
for the gradle installation
so this is the website of the jdk of a
java oracle java
now here you have different jdk so from
there you can do whatever the
option you want to select you can go
with that so jdk8 is something which is
most commonly used nowadays like it's
most comfortable
or compatible version which is available
so um
in case you want to see that if the jdk
is installed into your system all you
have to do is that you have to just say
like java
hyphen version and that will give you
the output that whether the java is
installing to your system or not
so in case my system the java is
installed but if you really want to do
the installation
you have to download the jdk installer
from this website
from this article website and then you
can proceed further on that part
now once the jdk is installed so you
have to go for the cradle installation
because cradle is something though
which will be performing the build
automations and all that stuff
so you have to download the binaries
like the zip file probably in which we
have the executables and all
and then we have to have have some
particular environment variables
configured so that we will be able to
have the
system modified over there so right now
we have got like the pre requests as in
java version installed
now the next thing is that we have to
install or download the executables
so uh in order to download the latest uh
gradle distribution so you have to click
on this one
right now over here there are different
options like you want to go for 6.7 now
it's a having like binary only is or
complete
we'll go for the binary only because we
don't want to have the source we just
want the binaries and the executables
now it's getting downloaded it's around
close to 100 mb of the installer which
is there
now we have to just extract into a
directory and then the same
path we need to configure into the
environment variable so that in that way
we will be able to see that how
the uh gradle executables will be
running and it will give the
complete output to us over here in this
case so it may take some time and once
the
particular modifications and the
download is done then we have to extract
it and once the extraction is done
so we will be able to go back and
have some particular version or have the
configurations
established over there so that let's
just wait for some time and then we will
be continuing with the environment
variables
like this one so once the installation
and the extraction is done now we just
have to go to the downloads
where this one is downloaded we have to
extract it
now extraction is required so that we
can have the setup like
we can set up this path into our
environment variables and once the path
is configured and established we will be
able to start further on that path
on the execution so meanwhile these
files are getting
started let's see so we already got the
folder structure over here
and uh we will see that we will give
this path here
there is two environment variables we
have to configure one is the gradle
underscore home and one is the
in the path variable so we'll copy this
path here so meanwhile this is getting
uh
extracted we can save our time and we
can go to the
environment variable so we can right
click on this one properties
in there we have to go for the advanced
systems settings
then environment variables now here we
have to give it like
gradle underscore home now in this one
we will not be going giving it till the
bin directory so that
only needs to be there where the griddle
is extracted so we'll say okay
and uh then we have to go for the path
variable where we will be adding up a
new entry
in this one we will be putting up till
the pin directory here because
the gradle executable should be there
when i'm running the gradle command
so these two variables i have to
configure then okay okay
and okay so this one is done so now you
have to just open the command prompt
and see that whether the execution or
the commands which you're running is
is completely successful or not so
meanwhile it's extracting all the
executables and all these things
it will help us to understand that how
the whole build process or how the build
tools can be integrated over there
now once the extraction is done so you
have to run like cmd
you have iphone version to check the
version of the java
and then the gradle
underscore version is what you're going
to see that you check the version of the
cradle
which is installed and now you can see
that it says that 6.7 version is being
installed over here in this case
so that's the way that how we are going
to have the cradle installation
performed into our particular system so
that's it for this one thanks
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here